Welcome to this episode of trash taste. I am the boy, the big boy. And with me,
I have big boy youngest and small boy Chagas. Wow.
Why am I suddenly the fattest one here? [inaudible].
I haven't seen either of you at the gym lately.
I don't know what's been going on with that, but you know,
I'm very disappointed.
One, they got a C in cholesterol are so late.
[inaudible] on that. I want it to open up that cause you know what I was, I was,
I was seeing my usual trash tastes, um,
schedule and a on the toilet literally before recording got to get a,
get a phone call from Sydney and she said, Oh, I finally get my health,
health results back in. I'm like, congratulations. What'd you get Sydney.
And she got all A's and I'm like, cough, Sydney,
off. You got all A's.
So how was it that she gets all A's and yet I got a C on my liver.
I'm probably the one out of the foremost who drinks the least. Okay. Okay. So,
so to give context of this conversation. So a few weeks ago,
if you have regular trash tastes viewer,
you would know that we had our biannual annual health check annual
health check. Yeah. And.
Just something that a Japanese company forces every employee to do,
they have to go for a checkup and the company also gets the results. Yeah.
Yes. And so we did, we did our health checkup a few weeks ago.
We talked about it on trash taste and we just got our results back.
And this is the first time I've ever gotten results back from like, uh,
you know, getting my health checkup in a foreign company, a country. Sorry.
And I did not know that you get graded. I'm used to seeing numbers.
And them saying like, Oh, this is bad. I'm like, Oh, wow.
I mean, it's just a funny number, isn't it? Yeah, no, no, it literally,
I got my health checkup and I'm just like, wait,
they are literally grading you ABC. Like it's like an end of year score report.
I felt like I was doing my GCSE is again, or Hey levels, Mike, my God.
And normally I don't really care too much about my health checkup because I've
done it. This is bad. Right. You see numbers, you see, you know,
you see the doctor's suggestions and they're,
they're just that they're doctors just suggestions. But I don't know why.
I think it's seeing,
seeing my health being graded like a school test.
It just brought the Asian blood out.
Yeah. I definitely felt more competitive.
Yeah. My body.
Cause I was going through my health checkup and overall I got a B,
so I was like, okay, I am a straight a student. What is,
what the did I do wrong? I'll be an Asian. There is no, no dead
B means bad dead.
The first thing I did when I got my results was I phoned up my mom and
told her that and told her how well I scored in this exam.
I called up the doctor and I was like, just to check this wasn't ranked, was it?
This was, this is casual. This is free play. Right. Please say,
please say this society let's say no, but I, yeah. So I mean, my results,
I got like all A's, which is great.
I should expect from someone who is under the age of 30,
you're generally supposed to be quite healthy, but I got it. I got to be on BMI.
Which, I mean, obviously I'm built a little different. Yeah.
And this is Japanese BMI, which I believe is slightly different.
I don't know if I'm, if I'm led to believe. That's correct, but yes, but I mean,
BMI is anyway, all of the, this is a hundred percent muscle,
not fat don't have me. And they got a C on my cholesterol,
but I got, I got like a, well, I'm not sure how cholesterol work exactly.
Because I don't know I'm dumb. Um, but one of, so there was like,
they'll have like three different collaterals and all of them were like a
little, you know, all the mechanics out of touch. Right. Um,
but I was like, in my head, I'm like, well,
they gave me three CS now for my cholesterol. I'm like,
but what are the odds of one of these cholesterol being good and the others not
being good? You know what I mean? If I got amazing cholesterol, the other two,
I'm going to be like, well. I mean, well, we're going to pick it up. I mean,
I don't know to me it was odd.
That was worse because I got to see my liver and I think a B on my heart rate
monitoring or something and everything else was an a, does that mean
it's a, usually on your thing,
like I think YouTube got like a doctor's like note, right? Or like a doc.
Did you guys get a doc? So you can ask.
When you get the thing. I don't know if you said yes or no,
you can ask if you want advice. And I said, no, I don't want.
I said no, but I still got like, I've got,
I don't know if it's the same Dr. Snyder we're talking about,
but it was just like a summation of the test results.
We should just explain anything. No, it didn't. It just said, um,
some of the values are a bit, you know, abnormal, which is, you know,
a higher or lower than we expect,
but there shouldn't be anything to worry about. I didn't even get a summation.
Did you know?
My literally like overall I got a C and the summation box was just blank.
I was like, Oh, you're just going to tell me that my liver is bad.
And that's it. I feel like content context would help.
Did you have to get,
did you get a note that said you had to come in three months later?
Well, like I got that. They told me back in three months, but I don't, I don't,
but it's optional.
On the thing. It says, like, if you get a seed,
they recommend you come back three months later,
but I didn't get like a note saying that I should come back to mindset.
You should come back and do that.
I have to pay for it. And also, you know,
for cholesterol that he's obviously going to turn up and they're going to be
like, Hey, you should, uh, exercise and eat healthy. I'm like.
Thanks dog. I was going to ask. Cause I heard,
I heard your back when the chicken and broccoli diets. No, I haven't.
Back to the chicken and broccoli.
I have started eating a little more health conscious because of the test
results. I think it helped, helped me be a bit more conscious. It made me,
you know, when you would,
you would maybe just go for the game or you would go for the chips and maybe be
a little like second thing. Like.
I mean, I, I definitely have like stopped drinking. So I think,
I think I've only drank like once or twice a.
Is, is, is the liver a hundred percent, all problems come from alcoholics?
I feel like it's not just.
Probably going to be a whole host of,
cause the problem with the test results is that they, they gave,
they gave you the grade, but they didn't tell you how to improve it.
And I guess, I guess that was all bad.
Cause we literally tick the box that said we don't want doctor's advice because
I had assumed like any other health checkup that it would just be like,
you know, you're gonna be good. Right. It was just like the generic, you know,
are you doing well?
Do I need to go to the hospital to really have a whole lifestyle change? No,
but as soon as I saw the bee, cause I got a,
I got a B in my blood and I'm just like, how the do I improve my blood?
What am I doing wrong? Why is my blood a B just improve your Nan?
Just like control. Like, cause they, they were like, they were like, go on like,
you know, the white blood was T-cell I don't, I'm not a nut.
I, I still don't know because I was like, I'm going to be yes.
Yeah. I saw the beat and I'm just like, as, as, as an agency don't, you know,
cause whenever I saw it being a test, I'm like, okay,
I can improve this test score. I can study a bit more.
I can optimize this a bit more.
Somehow what I found interesting was that like I always thought to myself that I
was very deaf for my age because you know,
I went to like a lot of concerts growing up and just,
basically destroyed my Easter, like headphones and like that.
But so I was expecting like on the hearing part that maybe get like a B or
something. Right. I wouldn't even have complained about it.
But then I saw I got an a yeah. So I was like, Oh, it's not that I'm deaf.
It's just that I don't listen.
[inaudible] realize. I was like, okay, I'm glad to know.
I don't have a hearing problem. I just have like an attention problem.
I just don't give a. That's my fault.
I was telling, I was telling the company, I was like, listen, if,
if my eyesight or my ears come back. I know exactly why that is.
And that's because I didn't know what the was happening when they were talking
to put the headphones on me. I'm like, wait, what? Wait, Whoa. They were like,
can you, then she asked me, luckily I just called her asking,
can you hear in Japanese? Like, can you hear it? And I'm like.
He'll walk. What am I listening for? And then I realized.
Because I had done the human benchmark tests recently that it was the frequency
thing to hear it. But I was like, what do you, what do you mean? Like,
what am I hearing for like a book? Like what?
I didn't know where it was happening. I say thing. Right?
You have to do like the it's like a circle cut out, right? Yeah.
I did you guys say that in English? No. I said it in Japanese just point.
Oh really? I cause I,
I really up in the eyesight thing because I didn't know what they were looking
for.
So I thought it was like a normal eyesight test thing where now when I was just
like, Oh, E because, because, okay, so to explain the eyesight thing,
they have this circle and have like one of like either up,
down left or right that's cartel and the diagonals as well. Water cut out.
I didn't see diagonals. I didn't see.
No, no, no. I only saw up down there for all of them, right? Yeah, I did too.
But there was diagonal. There was no, there was no, I, they gave me,
they usually have diagonals. Right. I've never seen.
I knew about this task just because when I exchanged my driving license from
British to Japanese, I have to do the exact same thing. Right. And I was just,
it was this exact same thing again. And there was no diagonals.
I mean, I definitely got a ride cause I came back with like a 1.2 eyes.
No, because right next to the circle thing, you had like the letters as well.
So I was just reading out letters when they were asking what direction I would
have said what's missing from this
because I was wondering why she was looking at me really weird. I'm just like,
and she kept asking me, can you see? Can you see? And I'm just like, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Let me just read out the letters. [inaudible].
Yeah. Luckily I had done the simulation before,
so that's why I was not panicking as much, but yeah man,
I mean I clicked no to the health advice cause I just figured that it was going
to be the same old, you know, eat healthy because let's be honest. Right.
If it's, if it's, unless it's something, you know, bad, like really bad,
that actually requires treatment. Right. They're just going to tell me, Hey,
you should exercise more and eat healthy. You. I do most of that anyway. Yeah.
Because I mean like I think for cholesterol, it's pretty simple.
It's pretty simple. But for some of them, like for example, liver or blood,
you look at that with a little yikes.
It's like a number of factors, right?
It's like, what do you want to start with? How do I,
how do I improve my white blood cell count? I don't know. Do I,
do I just take an injection of white blood cells? Well,
what'd you what'd you want me to do.
I have a theory, right? This, this is, this could be a very, uh,
pleasant theory. I don't know. I, I,
my theory was cause we got the health checkup done right after like Christmas.
And my theory was, well,
I just been drinking and eating straight for like three weeks.
This is just clean. We've got to write this off. This is,
of course my collateral is going to be higher.
I had like 8,000 calories three days ago. Of course it's going to be higher.
Maybe. I don't know. I have to drink a lot in Christmas. So yeah.
So much. Yeah. Yeah.
I think I definitely skewed the results.
That's that's what I'm going to chalk it down to.
[Inaudible] please validate me in the comments. I don't want,
I don't want to hear it. If you have an alternative theory, just say.
Yeah, I just found, I just found it funny how, like, I think it's, I think it's,
this is different.
Definitely the difference between like Asian culture and like Western culture
where I feel like in Asia, living in Asia,
they try to make everything a test and everything kind of competitive.
And that's just, I that's how I was raised as well. So whenever I see a grade,
I like something in my blood drives me to try and improve that grades. Yeah.
That's true. Yeah. And I don't know if I'm just like over competitive or I just,
maybe.
I think it's good, right? Because if you're the kind of person who you are.
Yeah. Those, those things worked really well,
but there's obviously some personalities out there that when they hear, Oh,
by the way, like you'll be a mice battery live is bad where they just like,
instead of like wanting to be like, well you, I'm going to improve it.
It's like, Oh. I guess it's just like, there's no hope. Like why,
why is it like working? And then he should make it worse. Right?
Yeah. But I dunno. I feel like as, as you know, as someone who grew up in,
you know, kind of, kind of both cultures,
I think a lot of toxicity can come and putting so much value into a
grade or a test. And I feel like definitely living in Asia,
they put way too much value into test results and score results.
Steve,
do you think there are like some schools and like companies where like they get
bullied if you got like a bad rating?
I think it's totally,
I it's a thing in Asia because I heard because got a Dean is because,
because in, in, in Asia, I don't know if I'm talking out my,
but you see in like anime definitely where you get the test results. Right.
And it's like publicly posted. So you,
you publicly know what your fellow classmates got.
And that to me seems like a lot of pressure.
And I feel like university like entrance exams as well.
They like create a huge billboard in front of the school.
And it has like your number on it. And if your number doesn't show up,
you basically failed.
It's like a public execution eventually make a public tournament arc for your
test results. No one know that they put so much value on tests.
And I think that can,
I can definitely see that to me from my experience can definitely skew with your
mentality when you go out of schooling and you realize that not everything in
life is graded and not everything in life has a percentage or a grade.
That's a judges, your results and how well you do. Yeah.
Of the given the industry that we've gone into, which is entertainment,
if you will. Uh, but if you called trash tastes entertainment,
but we're trying our best here. Um,
I feel like the skill set is nearly one 80 in compares of what you
learn in school. Right. It's purely based on, like,
I feel like social skills are 90% of our job. Yeah. Right.
Being able to read a room, being able to like talk, you know? And it, I mean,
obviously there is a lot of technical aspects,
obviously like learning how to set up all this equipment,
but the majority of it can't be taught in a classroom and it's kind of,
and you can't grade it. How can you grade someone social skills?
And that's when we started doing that.
Oh.
You know, you were an,
but ever since the event happened to you that you've come kind of a bummer.
You're kind of a D now, you know what I mean?
Yeah. It's like, it's like getting graded for every tweet you make. Right.
Honestly.
Well, yeah, that's true. He's just going to fight away.